first time I just reorganized remember
getting in the car and I had 3 000
Twitter followers wow second time I did
Rogue and I told the machine story and I
went to the club and it was sold out
third time I did Rogan I made a machine
shirt the machine shirt that I chose I
got home to my house and Leanne goes
we sold 25 000 worth of t-shirts because
I don't have those made woke up the next
morning she goes we sold 90 000 worth of
t-shirt in like two days Joe wore it at
a weigh-in boot you've no bikes huge I
go to I go to different countries I
remember Amsterdam and they were yelling
the machine in Amsterdam and I was like
what the I mean so so it's funny
you'd just get high and talk for three
hours and not remember any of it yeah at
all crazy to see where he is today and
it doesn't make sense to me